corríjanme pero tengo entendido que
usted fue el único presidente en la
historia de colombia que visitó en reino
unido a la reina isabel que recuerda de
ese viaje y de la reina
así es fue una visita de estado cuando
yo era presidente
fue la visita más importante
y más sentirá que tuvimos durante mi
mandato presidencial
una visita muy especial porque
ese año
había cancelado el rey de españa
entonces no sino una sola visita de
estado y a mí me acaban de entregar el
premio nobel de paz y eso para la visita
pues fue un
incentivo para que los británicos como
dicen en colombia sacaran todos los
fierros necesitan una visita llena de
anécdotas
agradables positivos
lo que recordamos es momentos
inolvidables que tuvimos de generaciones
personales y de presiones diplomáticas
entre la familia real la familia mía y
colombia- de inglaterra yo he sido muy
cercana a los ingleses desde hace mucho
tiempo yo viví 10 años encontré mi
primer contacto con la familia real yo
tenía unos
11 años en el año 62 el príncipe felipe
vino a colombia y estudiaba en un
colegio inglés colegio anglo colombiano
y recuerdo muy bien cuando el príncipe
felipe se iba a dirigir a los
estudiantes
y tenía unas palabras escritas en el
papel que tenía lo puso en bolsillo
improviso y dijo que a mí nunca me gustó
ir al colegio y a partir del momento en
que termine esas paradas ustedes tienen
el día libre
entonces la primera impresión mía fue
muy positiva por supuesto de esa familia
real años después no sean setentas
cuando vivía en londres yo
anuncia la agraciada
era diplomático y o trabaja con la
federación de cafeteros de colombia pero
era parte de la embajada entonces íbamos
cuando había presentación de
credenciales o cuando había los eventos
tradicionales que la reina organizaba en
el palacio de pop están allá conocidas
a todos los miembros de la familia real
y cuando fuimos en visita al estado pues
fue algo muy especial
y todo el protocolo que tienen los
ingleses
la visita a diferentes sitios del primer
ministro el ministro
de ese entonces de relaciones exteriores
que era bonito aunque después fue el
primer ministro me dijo porque sabía que
yo era aficionado a churchill él era muy
aficionada con él escribió un libro
sobre churchill que se llama el factor
churchill entonces me llevó a las
bóvedas
donde el chino
llegó
la guerra un momento muy especial con el
príncipe carlos
y yo lo había conocido
cuando vino a colombia lo llevé a un
sitio maravilloso que se llama el parque
chiribiquete que externa es el sitio
donde hay la mayor concentración de
biodiversidad del mundo entero él quedó
muy impresionado muy emocionado y yo lo
he dicho desde ese momento que yo soñaba
con tener
una tecnología un aparato tecnológico
con la tecnología de hoy que nos
permitiera hacer una segunda expedición
botánica como la que había hecho von
humboldt pero que pudieran descubrir y
descifrar el adn de las especies que en
colombia todavía existían que por la
guerra nuestra en colombia no se han
podido descubrir y que ese era un sueño
que yo tenía y cuando fui a la visita de
estado él me dijo vamos al museo de
historia natural
de tengo la sorpresa y la sorpresa era
que ya había una científica colombiana
entre avilés y químicos que estaban ahí
que me entregó o me mostró el aparato y
tomó muestras de una mariposa colombiana
y una hoja de la planta colombiana
efectivamente la puso en el aparato y el
adn en tiempo real comenzó a aparecer en
un computador se emocionó mucho de la
visita espectacular desde todo punto de
vista